[Music]
let's go out
to Northern Oklahoma otherwise known as
Vancouver Canada what's up David how we
doing
brother hey Dr thank you for taking my
call thanks for calling in man what's
up hi so um just have a question I need
help here um how do I tell my parents
that I haven't been going to school for
the last 5
years uh do you have a
pen yeah I got uh got my laptop here all
right type
this dear Mom and
Dad y I have not been going to school
for the last five
years
period how about how about
that yeah um tell me about it what
happened man what
happened yeah I like I know i' I've been
planning to like I just find the right
time there's not gonna be a right time
dude you're just gonna have to do it but
tell me tell me what happened for five
years you've been lying to your folks
what you been doing with the money
tuition what have you been
doing yeah so I haven't been taking any
money for tuition um also in the last
five years uh some stuff happened with
my mom um her mental health has been
getting worse uh she she got diagnosed
with uh delusional disorder so right now
she's uh not in the best shape so I'm
just scared like telling her this this
news is just going to make her even
worse so maybe she's not the best person
to tell what about your
dad my
dad I know my dad has been stressed out
too because of my mom and and I want to
tell him and I know he I think he knows
there's something up with me but
like how I'm just scared like how should
I tell them like hold on let's let's
back up let's back up dude um what
happened five years ago that you started
telling the story and you've been lying
for five years what have you been doing
for five
years yeah so during these five years I
know that I had to do something not just
waste time um so I I got a good job uh I
renting my own place so I'm not there um
I'm making money myself so I can uh I
can take care of
myself so I what are you doing what are
you
doing uh I'm an account manager at a
marketing company right now okay and
you're making a good living do you have
a good career
trajectory yeah do you like
marketing yeah do you need a a degree
for the job you have have you deceived
your
bosses no uh so even my bosses know
what's going on with my situation and uh
I've been doing a great job so I've been
here for a while a couple years so I've
been doing great and they love me here
and I love my job so why do you why do
you feel like have you been actively
lying to your parents why do you feel
like you need to come clean with
them because I don't want to like have
this like livee forever and I can feel
it in my chest like whenever they ask me
about school like I it's just hard to
talk to them about that and I I know
they they deserve to know the truth yeah
especially they deserve I mean if you've
been telling them if they ask you like
hey how school going you're like I got
finals coming up they're going to be
tough if you're doing that then yeah man
stop lying to your parents dude
um I want to get at the root of this and
I'm asking this not because it's okay to
perpetuate a half a decade lie to your
parents it's never
okay
and
I want to know why you felt you had to
do this in the first place and what I'm
asking is have your parents been if your
mom's just now getting um diagnosed with
some sort of um delusion disorder and
your dad is
struggling it's never okay to lie but
was it an unsafe place for you to be
honest and say hey I'd rather just go to
the workforce instead of go to college
um or were you just did you take a
chicken way out when you were 18 or 19
you just don't know how to how to reel
it back in
now I think I at first it was a chicken
way out during when I was 18 fresh out
of high school um I did try to tell them
like in high school that after when I
started my first semester in uh
University that they uh I didn't want to
be a doctor anymore and my mom pretty
much like uh guilted me into it saying
like uh you're wasting my my talent or
like we work so hard um we just want you
to be a doctor I guess it's like
following my uh my parents's dream but
which is mine so I felt really guilty
about that and then couple years after
that um mom's mental health got worse
and I just couldn't find the right time
to tell them I want you to pick up a
book um check real quick um Kelly it's
either I think it's Lindsay
Gibson it's called adult children of
emotionally immature
parents okay I think it's lindsy C
Gibson is that the
author adult children of emotionally
immature parents yes it is a small book
David and it is a
masterpiece I ended up um I should have
highlighted my book with a sharpie and
just highlighted the I mean just crossed
out the parts that I didn't highlight
because I basically highlighted the
entire
book what you're describing
is you were have you've been a part of a
world where it's your
job to live out your parents'
fantasies and unfortunately that's not
your
job
actually fortunately it's not your
job right yeah
and that doesn't give you Liberty to
cash in your um integrity and lie to
your parents so the easy answer is I
follow two principles number one I only
speak if people can hear
me if your mom is struggling with the
with the delusion
disorder um then and she can't hear
you your dad probably can and so I would
tell my dad dad I need to talk to you in
person do you live in the same town as
him yeah okay Dad I need to take you to
a meal it needs to be just us too and I
have a heavy conversation I need
conversation I need to have with you I'm
safe and I'm okay but I need to have a
hard conversation with
you and the way I would approach this
conversation after you let him know that
way he at least comes ready he's not
just going to be eating a pancake and
all of a sudden you're like hey for the
last 5 years I've been lying to you all
the
time um so you let him know and he'll
sit down and say what's going on and and
it's important to say I'm safe I'm
healthy I'm
okay and then you let him know Dad for
five years I haven't told you the
truth and I would actually seek to
soften the blow a little bit and say for
the last three and and half years I've
been working at such and such marketing
firm as an account manager making a good
living I never went to college I lied to
you for four years or five years and I'm
sorry and then you stopped
talking I wish there was more complex
like more like there was a switch to
flip there was something to like and
then do the there's not
but what he's going to want to know out
of the gate is my boy okay is my boy
safe what happened and then he'll get to
the I can't believe you lied to me and
he may have been telling his friends for
five years my son's going to be a doctor
my son's going to be a doctor he may
have been making decisions financially
because my boy's going to be a doctor my
boy's going to be a
doctor and no matter how successful you
are financially he's going to have to
wrestle with the fact that his son has
lied to him for five years
so you're going to need to be very
graceful with what he says next because
he has not shown that he's got good
emotional regulation up until this point
so I wouldn't expect it just suddenly to
appear out of
nowhere but he's going to get some need
some
time fair
enough yeah sounds good okay what I
don't want you to do is to turn around
and make his response his fault make him
the victim in what comes next okay
yeah this is about you doing what's
right and if he chooses to just go
bananas and yell and scream and or walk
out on you whatever then he's Cho
choosing um to revert back to some
childhood Behavior he gets to do that
and then you're going to have to make
some hard decisions about what comes
next but you're going to keep your
character and your dignity and respect
intact
Fair
yeah so what are you going to say to
him just going to tell him the truth I'm
going to tell him
that I haven't been going to school for
the last five years I'm sorry for lying
to you but uh I've been working nope no
no no no butts after that tell them
you've been working first and then say
I've been lying to you I have not gone
to
school got it and then there's a period
at the end because there's not a butt
after
that okay like because butt suggests
like
I haven't been doing this but it's okay
because it's not I've been lying to you
man I'm just going to sit here in this
awkwardness in this intention I'm going
to own it and then I think it's
important for you to also tell them I'm
choosing to tell you because I know
mom's not
okay
yeah and normally I would tell you both
but I have more trust in you right
now and he might start weeping he might
get up and walk away what do you when
you imagine this knowing your dad cuz I
obviously don't know him what do you
think he's going to
do since
uh that the best right now I think he
might uh might try
or just not talk to me for a while okay
I hate that for
you I hate that for
you yeah but also I don't want the a
potential adverse outcome for you to um
be the reason you don't be a person of
integrity and can we can we put a stick
in the ground a steak in the ground and
say I'm never going to lie again I'm G
always tell the
truth yeah does that sound
fair yeah I won't
okay even though this is going to be
hard are you at
peace yeah I'm pretty uh happy with
myself just not
this Li have okay let's let it let's let
it rip man and
um uh let me know how it goes right back
into the show and let me know how the
conversation goes and um this probably
won't come up but if your dad wants to
talk to me be happy to talk to him as
well sounds like he's had a really tough
go of it as of late but I want you to
pick up that book um we'll link to it in
the show notes it's just such a good
book I've got no Financial incentive
it's just one of those uh few books that
is so so so good
and for everybody out
there secrets will kill
you Secrets will kill you tell the
truth